oh mec c'est tellement fip en viendront
d'ici deux jours surtout pour ce
troisième épisode de lie à offrir ce
petit let's play repro visées sur ce
peintre fou mais comment a t'il pas son
tableau que ces partis de quoi était
toujours dans cette petite pièce et on
veut en savoir plus sur comment il a
peint son tableau
qu'at-il fait à la fin à part avoir tué
sa femme son enfant et bientôt son chien
un placard voilà plein de rats de rats
partout même sur les tableaux la seule
solution le feu n'en fais pas ça avec
kim en faire à chaque fois [ __ ] mais
j'en ai marre il ya un mec il ya un mec
est ce moi je vais raconter cette
anecdote chez que des couches tevez il
ya un mec son rôle dans ce jeu c'est
fermé les portes dès que je les passe au
wat un phoque ckoi mec c'est quoi ce
tableau glauque l'a arraché avec un ara
homme et un pit stop stop et qu'il faut
que j'aille au milieu non ok
hu arrêtez arrêtez j'en ai marre à
rester je suis sensible comme garçons ça
me fait flipper le muscat sec sans
déconner là la porte finale de via rail
europe pire
[ __ ] c'est tellement beau c'est
incroyable le daily mail alléluia ils
s'évanouissaient de la plume est calme
toi et je me réveille dans la petite
pièce sombre tâche d'avoir mal aux
doigts à force de me réveiller mon
bouquet de ce [ __ ] de park et tout dur
c'est de me péter le bas du dos portage
par le poème de dieu bonjour ça va quoi
allez allez allez
ouais ouais ouais je ne regarde pas
derrière ces tests
en plus moi tu me jette par terre on
voit tes seins rapidement je crois que
les pas remarqué mais j'ai l'oeil alors
éveil douloureux pour le dos sur ce
parquet bonjour cette fois je leur dis
plus derrière qu'on n'est pas regarder
derrière au revoir au quai dans le
placard yann barthes [ __ ] moulias le
gard repousse toutes les limites quoi
mais c'est quoi tout ça un peu de
souffrance l'emmène sur un long chemin
ouais mais je fais quoi là je fais quoi
ouais watts
ça donne des frissons j'ai fait mal
acquis à qui je veux voir à kg infligé
de la souffrance ok et surtout dans
l'ascenseur bas allons-y j'ai envie de
te dire fais toi plaisir à aller à et
voulait pas se faire plaisir le conte
qu'est ce qu'on va voir
iam tout temps du hockey même
l'ascension un peu pourquoi non là
j'aime retourner au grain porte
allez allez je te plaît [ __ ] on y
prend goût à ce métier sans déconner
allez c'est quoi ce bruit c'est quoi ce
bruit au dessus non là on voit un bon
vent à elle est là mais quel est le
[ __ ] de fans j'en ai marre
qu'est ce tu veux tu veux quoi tu veux
quoi tu l'as cherché travaillait du
matin tu tu me laisses empêche te plaît
non mais non je terrifiée je suis
terrifiée
non non ma chute sa chute sa chute
oh là là là là là et voilà arrivés sur
le parquet veille matin qu'un seul jour
avec une fleur avec le bas du dos
littéralement enflammé ont retrouvé quoi
c'est pas [ __ ] montrez nous comment
ils finissent ce truc à la fin la halle
au oui bon quoi arrête de pleurer arrêté
mon dieu tu m'as tu es sur 22 fois tu
peux plus de pourrir
elle est où oh non non mais tu passe te
plaît non non non je veux pas y aller
non j'y vais à contrecoeur je ferme la
porte
excuse moi voilà on tourne t orange maps
longs trajets en faire des gens bat les
couilles je me dire de la déteste un
truc de ouf je déteste cette femme sait
pas ce qui lui a fait dans le jeu mais
je la déteste quoi oui allô oui oui
téléphone la ouate de musique ou est-ce
d'ailleurs là ça s'ouvre c'est un pas
nommé
quoique je fasse quoi oh là là où se
trouve le numéro c'est ça allait bonjour
l'enigma le bras un livre secret un truc
là non tu lui de lumière il va se passer
un truc sur tableau monica knickel c'est
bon ça marche alpes ma [ __ ] ça sonne
ailleurs non mais t'es sérieux
la quête du téléphone qui veut juste que
je regarde en l'air au bugue watteau non
mais quoi et y est tombé là vient enfin
qu'elle suit et qui a tué son enfant
ou enfin c'est que c'est bien on a
découvert ça mais ça changera ma
situation de merde je suis bloqué avec
un téléphone qui sonne
voilà maintenant il ya une porte ici qui
est téléphone
merci d'avoir joué à l'aller access aux
flyers offerts on espère que vous avez
qui fait et on attend votre feedback
restez connectés pour plus de folie au
métier les gens c'est déjà fin de
secours let's play de deux épisodes
ouais franchement c'est des coups j'ai
bien aimé le jeu le principe du mec
foutu dit pourquoi il écrit ce qu'il a
fait puis tu le découvres gumboots été
assez sympa qu'est ce qui vous a plu
aussi à vous savez j'ai décroché la lune
pour vos yeux vous êtes si beau mais ça
vous regarde on se trouvait dans une
prochaine vidéo portez vous bien tu as
tout le monde et à bientôt